I love this story the Catholic Church
and the Vatican are now scrambling after
Pope Francis sort of appeared to
question whether there even is a hell
which is kind of a pretty basic belief
of Catholicism but you don't have to
worry because the flunkies are claiming
he was just misunderstood what happened
is that during a recent meeting Eugenio
Scalf re who's the now 93 year old
founder of a Vatican newspaper asked
Pope Francis where do bad Souls go of
course the correct answer in the context
of the Catholic Church is supposed to be
while they go to hell and Pope Francis
is quoted by Scalf Ari as saying quote
they are not punished those who repent
obtain God's forgiveness and take their
place among the ranks of those who
contemplate him but those who do not
repent and cannot be forgiven disappear
a hell doesn't exist the disappearance
of sinning Souls exists this led to
panic at the Vatican that should be a
name for a funny romantic comedy panic
at the Vatican and if you're the Vatican
you you sort of need the threat of
eternity in hell to get people to fall
in line right this is one of the ways in
which you get people to do what you want
them to do is convince them that if they
don't do what you want them to do that
they're gonna end up spending an
eternity in hell they are writing this
off as a misquote but they're not even
offering an alternative meaning they're
just saying quotes of the Pope are not
accurate the Vatican said that the quote
literal words pronounced by the Pope are
not quoted and that quote no quotation
of the article should be considered as a
faithful transcription of the words of
the Holy Father then the other
interpretation explaining what's going
on here is that what he meant
isn't that hell doesn't exist but that
hell as a place of fire and brimstone
and misery isn't real like there's no
hell if you imagine the burning Inferno
but there is how if it's just separation
from God and the disappearance of the
soul or something like that but then
you're really finding an explanation it
just fit what it was
that was allegedly said here the problem
with that is that there are endless poor
trails of Hell by Catholics as exactly a
place of fire and brimstone in their own
scriptures in the book of Revelation in
Corinthians anyway I don't really care
about the specifics I just love how this
Pope who is from Argentina by the way
has thrown the Catholic Church into
these moments of chaos as a result of
just steering away even slightly from
some of the orthodoxy of the church and
the one sort of caveat here is that the
interviewer Scalf Ari Eugenio Scalf Ari
he does have somewhat of a history of
being I guess I'll call it fast and
loose with the truth in some cases but
it still seems weird that he would make
up an interview whole cloth but both
from a sort of marketing and PR
perspective for his newspaper and from a
legal perspective but this is a super
interesting because we've been following
the move away from Catholicism that's
been going on you've seen people leaving
Catholicism because they've stopped
being religious altogether right like
that's one layer which is in general
particularly younger generations are
becoming less and less religious over
time but there's this whole other angle
which is that there are Catholics who
have also just left Catholicism and
moved to Protestantism meaning non
Catholic Christianity and part of it has
to do with the specifics of the Catholic
Church and it's sort of feeling quite
frankly there's one of those possible
bingo phrases quite frankly like a dated
and sort of in in downfall organization
even though they still have like 1.2 1.3
billion adherents so it's gonna be an
interesting decade I think for the
Catholic Church up coming yeah and I
think that's why we're seeing such a
progressive Pope in Pope Francis I mean
the guy seems to be okay with gay
marriage he accepts that climate change
exists it's just interesting how saying
that hell doesn't exist is a bridge too
far for these Catholics yeah and there's
the last straw we can have that
straight-up panicking and saying that's
simply not what he said send me your
thoughts I know that there are current
and ex Catholics in the show audience
and I'd be interested in hearing from
them for sure the video you just watched
was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as one dollar per month and
every dollar helps to support the work
that we're doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad